before we go we can't get enough of them
let's go back to Iowa with Tony who's
gonna introduce us to a bulldog on the
boat who's on the most visit list for
presidential hopefuls well its
introduction please Tony you got a gal
this is grip the Bulldog he's the mascot
of Drake University and he's a very
popular stop on the campaign trail eight
different candidates who are still in
the race have made a pilgrimage here to
see Grif he hung out with Elizabeth
Warren's dog Bailey Pete Buddha judge
was here just last night and I think if
I give him one of these treats he might
make a prediction as to who's gonna win
the caucus is evening all right you're
gonna whisper it in my ear graft really
do you don't say oh it's a good one it's
gonna be a surprise tonight guys good
looks a little sad that all the
excitement is about to end in Iowa I was
gonna say grip looks like you're so over
it he's now he's just showing you his
but cuz he's had enough all right Tony
nice job this morning yeah you got to
meet a lot of great people very much
thank you very much see you tomorrow
travel safe
that'll do
you